- [Voiceover] Preaching to the Choir
the Health Benefits of Singing.
This is going to be interesting.
I like to sing.
All right.
So in 2013, and just a reminder,
when they put these
numbers in brackets here
they're numbering the
sentences in this paragraph.
That's different than
when they put the numbers
in these gray boxes,
that's when they're going to
refer to actual questions.
And in general when they start putting,
they don't do these for
all of the sentences
in these passages,
but when they do do these,
they tend to do them for the sentences
in a paragraph,
and they'll probably ask
us some question about
whether a sentence is
appropriate in a certain place,
or should it have been
moved around somehow,
so let's put ourselves
in that frame of mind,
especially for this first paragraph
that ends with this kind of question one.
So question one is probably going to refer
to the sentence structure
order in this paragraph,
so let's read it.
In 2013, 32.5 million
adults in the United States,
roughly ten percent of the population,
sang in choirs, and England
is home to more than
3000 active choral groups.
All right, a lot of people
in the United States
and England sing in choirs.
Choir singing is a popular pastime.
Well they've already
established that choir,
I mean, this data right
here is kind of telling us
that choir singing is a popular pastime,
I almost feel like this
sentence should maybe go
before the, you know, choir
singing is a popular pastime
and then you give the evidence.
In 2013, 32.5 million
adults in the United States,
roughly ten percent of the population,
sang in choirs, and England
is home to more than
3000 active choral groups.
Makes sense to me that sentence two
should actually go first.
These singers often
report an increased sense
of well-being and comaradarie,
but does this hobby actually
result in better health?
According to multiple
scientific studies, singing -
especially with others -
provides concrete benefits
to the heart and brain,
which I happen to believe, as well.
So let's see, I'm
guessing, not even looking,
I'm voiding looking at this just yet,
that they're gonna ask
us about sentence two,
because it feels like it has to go first.
To make the paragraph most logical,
sentence two, I was
right, and I'm serious,
I didn't look at this beforehand.
So I like to do this real time,
so that I can empathize.
Sentence two should be placed
at the beginning of the
paragraph, for sure.
That establishes that
choir singing is a popular
pastime, then they give evidence
that it is a popular pastime.
And then, you know,
here we're talking about
the number of singers,
and then they reference these singers,
so it makes sense if two goes
first, then one, then three.
On to the second paragraph,
and the second question.
A 2013 study at Sweden's
University of Gothenburg
examined the heart
rates of 18 young people
as they sang and hummed for unison.
All right, for just sounds strange,
you don't do things for unison,
you do things in unison.
And so let's see, question two,
well that's going to be in unison,
and that's just a standard convention,
if you're talking about doing something
you don't say for unison or on unison
or at unison, you say,
Hey, we're going to do this in unison.
So that, for sure, is going to be in.
Let's actually keep going,
I think we can do question
three of this video too.
Heart rate variability (HRV),
the increase and decrease in heart rate,
occured simultaneously with the subjects'
slowed breathing while singing.
This combination of fluctuating heart rate
and slowed breathing are called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia,
and has been proven to
reduce the likelihood
of cardiovascular disease,
a prior finding independent
of the 2013 study.
All right, so this first, this are is off,
because they're talking about,
what's the subject of this sentence.
It's this combination of
fluctuating heart rate
and slowed breathing
that are talking abot what
this combination is about,
but the subject is this combination
and that's singular, we're
talking about this combination,
a combination here.
So it's singular, we
say this combination are
respiratory sinus arrhythmia,
no, you say this combination is called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia.
So this is going to be is right over here.
So is called, because it's a singular,
this combination is called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia,
and it has been proven
to reduce the likelihood
of cardiovascular disease,
a prior finding independent
of the 2013 study.
So the way it's written right now
is really there's no pause here.
You know, I like to just kind of pause
after it has been proven
to reduce the likelihood
of cardiovascular disease.
And then maybe adding some kind of a
prior finding independent
of the 2013 study.
So let's see what they have here.
So, no change, no, I don't like that.
This one, a prior finding independent
of the 2013 study, that might be fine,
it's a (mumbling)
it's giving us a little
bit of extra information
but we don't need it, so I like that.
Putting a semi colon there,
a prior finding independent
of the 2013 study,
you're adding another
kind of clause there,
it feels like it's just
hanging on the end,
I wouldn't do that.
And then a prior finding
independent of the
2013 study, with a colon,
colon, I view that as kind of
giving more clarification or enumeration,
and this is kind of
giving more clarification.
But I definitely like the parentheses
right over here because
it's making it clear
that this last part,
that it has been proven
to reduce the likelihood
of cardivascular disease,
and they're just giving us, in a parenthetical,
a prior finding independent
of the 2013 study.
We're now on question five,
People feel a keen sense of bonding
when they sing together.
All right, so that sentence seems
like it's grammatically correct,
but let's see what the question says.
Which choice most effectively establishes
the main topic of the paragraph?
Okay, I see,
they either want us to say,
Okay, we can have no change
and say this sentence
is what we would keep
as our topic sentence.
Or maybe we would replace it with
one of these other options.
Well to figure out how we can establish
the main topic of the paragraph
I guess we're gonna have
to read the paragraph.
So I would actually probably
come back to question five after reading,
after going all the way
through question nine.
So let's see if we can
do that in this video.
Singing stimulates the right temporal lobe
of the brain and releases endorphins.
Endorphins blunt pain and
engender feelings of pleasure.
So this right over here,
so for number six,
to just kind of do a period
and then do another sentence,
it's not grammatically incorrect.
I mean, it's fine to say that singing
stimulates the right temporal lobe
of the brain and releases endorphins,
that's a sentence.
And then to say endorphins blunt pain
and engender feelings of pleasure.
But these two sentences
are very connected,
in fact, the second
sentence right over here
is giving us clarity
on what endorphins are.
So I would think about,
I would think about
kind of connecting them
a little bit better.
So let's see what the choices are,
what the choices are here.
So the first one is,
oh they actually didn't
put no change here,
so they definitely want us to change it
I guess the way this is written.
So the first choice is singing stimulates
the right temporal lobe of the brain
and releases endorphins,
which end up blunting
and engendered feelings
of pleasure.
Now that's not right, I mean,
just even, look if you end up blunting
and engender, those two verbs aren't even
in the same tense.
Blunting, blunting,
yeah, this is, you know,
blunting and endgendered,
it's breaking your parallel
construction, so to speak.
Endorphins, which blunt,
let's see.
Singing stimulates the right temporal lobe
of the brain and releases endorphins,
which blunt pain and engender
feelings of pleasure.
Yeah, that one could work
and it connects them better.
Let's see C,
endorphins, but they blunt,
no, you don't want to contradict it,
we're just explaining what endorphins do.
As this last choice,
endorphins, and they blunt.
No, I think this is very clear,
when you say which blunt,
you're clarifying what endorphins do,
so I like B there.
All right, let's keep going.
So now we can go to question seven,
So cortisol, a hormonal reaction to stress
and the secretion of
which the brain controls,
decreases after choir singing.
All right, so cortisol's a stress hormone
and it decreases after choir singing.
Meanwhile, oxytocin,
which the brain interprets
as a feeling of emotional
bonding, is increased.
So these are describing ways that make
people feel better
and I want to read this entire paragraph,
because at the end I want to go back
to question five and think
about the topic sentence.
So all of these good things are happening.
In a study at Oxford Brookes University,
researchers surveyed 375 people
who either sang alone, sang in a choir,
or participated in organized sports.
Those who sang in choir
reported the highest levels of happiness.
So everything we're talking about is,
Wow, this choir singing really
can make people happier.
So, and their kind of
citing kind of chemical,
we can point to kind of chemical things
happening in the brain that are
actually associated with more happiness
and less stress.
Due to its positive side effects,
therapists have used choir singing
as an element for those dealing
with depression and chronic pain.
So I kind of like the due to
its positive side effects,
because that is the reason why
therapists would use it.
So let's look at the other choices.
So I like due to, that's my default,
so despite its positive side effects
therapists have used choir singing
no, I mean they're using it because
of the positive side effects,
due to the positive side effects.
This isn't a contradiction to the fact
that it is positive side effects.
It's not, if, you know,
despite the fact that it's bad for people,
therapists are using it,
that would be a reason
to use the word despite.
But no, that doesn't make sense.
In addition to its positive side effects,
therapists have used choir singing
as an element for those dealing
with depression and chronic pain.
Well it's not in addition.
It's saying it's giving the cause of it
because due to its positive side effects,
this is why therapists are thinking about
using it as a way to deal with depression
and chronic pain.
And then besides, once again,
it's not a besides the
therapists have used
choir singing, that's because due to the
positive side effects,
it isn't on top of or another thing
that's seemingly unrelated.
So I'd definitely would go with no change.
Now let's go to question eight.
And once again, I'm
using a prototype version
where it says six out
of five, seven out five,
obviously it should not be out of five
because there's more
than five questions here.
Let's go to question eight.
So due to its positive side effects
therapists have used choir singing
as an element for those dealing
with depression and chronic pain.
An element feels a little weird,
an element of what,
let's see with what the other options are.
An accessory for those dealing with
depression and chronic pain.
An accessory I imagine more of a bit of a,
you know, it wouldn't be a process
like a choir singing, it
wouldn't be an activity,
I wouldn't call an activity an accessory,
or piece.
Well, accessory doesn't feel right there,
let's see,
choir singing as a supplement
for those dealing with depression
and chronic pain.
A supplement could be good,
because, you know, you
wouldn't make this the primary
treatment if someone has severe depression
or chronic pain, you wouldn't just say,
Hey, why don't you go start in a choir,
go start singing in a choir?
There's other things that the therapist
would probably do to help alleviate
or deal with the depression
and chronic pain.
But it would be a supplement
above and beyond, above and beyond
what kind of the more
traditional methods might be.
This could be something
to do on top of that.
Now an addendum, an addendum, once again,
this is like something that you add on
to other things,
it's kind of like a supplement.
But, you know, I view
an addendum to kind of
a presentation, or to a
kind of a position paper,
or something, something
I add on to the back of
something like that, like a proposal.
I wouldn't use that word if I'm talking,
you know, kind of treatment
or dealing with something.
And that's how I kind
of feel about accessory,
accessory is something that adds on,
but I think of an accessory as more of
a watch or a purse or something,
not as much as an element
to kind of go above and beyond
the existing treatment.
I like the word supplement here.
Well, let's keep going.
A study from an arts and
health research center
in Canterbury, England followed,
a study from an arts and
health research center
in Canterbury, England followed
the progress of patients
diagnosed with depression for a year
after they joined a choir.
Sixty percent of patients
reported improved mental health
at the end of the year.
And some were no longer experiencing
suffering from clinical depression.
So experiencing suffering,
that sounds weird,
you would I would say, no longer suffering
from clinical depression, maybe?
Or no longer experiencing
symptoms of clinical depression?
But I wouldn't have experiencing
and suffering there,
I would get rid of one of them.
Let's see what our options are.
And some were no longer reporting
that they were suffering
from clinical depression.
I mean, that reads well.
And some were no longer reporting
that they were suffering
from clinical depression.
But it still feels a little bit heavy.
You know, reporting that
they were suffering,
is that necessary, could you just say,
Some were no longer suffering.
Let's see this next one.
And some were no longer suffering
from clinical depression
by the end of the year.
Well, this one is tempting,
but we already said
at the end of the year,
at the end of that year,
and then to say by the
end of that year, again?
Sixty percent of patients
reported mental health
at the end of that year
and some were no longer suffering
clinical depression by
the end of that year,
you're saying by the
end of that year twice,
that's redundant.
If it just said suffering
from clinical depression
I actually wouldn't mind this choice.
Let's see, I hope D works out well.
Sixty percent of patients
reported improved mental health
at the end of that year
and some were no longer
clinically depressed.
Yeah, that feels good.
Nice and clean.
Gets the point across.
All right, so we've answered through nine,
we go to remember, we skipped five
because five is about,
well, what's a good topic sentence
for that entire paragraph?
So everything they talked about
up here they're just talking about,
Hey, look, it makes people feel
feelings of pleasure
and they even see it in the endorphins,
you feel less stress hormone,
gets decreases, you feel
feeling of emotional bonding
goes up, and, you know, to
give even more evidence,
they say the researchers have even used it
to help alleviate, to
deal with the depression
and chronic pain.
So let's see, these choices,
singing in a choir can
help prevent depression.
Well, that's the second
half of the paragraph
does talk about that,
but that's not the whole paragraph.
The whole paragraph isn't
just about depression.
They're using depression as an example of
how singing in a choir can
help make you feel better.
So I wouldn't say that this is a topic,
if this was the topic sentence,
I don't know whether I would
go as heavily on all of
this other stuff here,
I'd probably just start right over here.
Let's see, the brain
tends to respond favorably
to group singing.
Yeah I think, I think this is good,
the brain tends to respond favorably
to group singing,
let's see how this reads.
The brain tends to respond
favorably to group singing.
Singing stimulates the right temporal lobe
of the brain and releases endorphins.
Yeah, we go straight into
talking about the brain.
Endorphins blunt pain
and engender feelings
of pleasure,
so we're talking about all the ways
that the brain reacts.
And even when we're
talking about depression,
we're talking about how it helps the brain
deal with these things.
So yeah, I like choice C there, so yeah,
we've done all the way
through question nine.
So the next video we can
do that last few questions.
So we're now on question ten,
and in question ten they
just have a box here
without any of the underline,
so they're not gonna ask us to
actually change something,
they're probably going to ask
us something more generally
about the paragraph,
so let's see what they ask us.
At this point, so they
are asking something
more general about the paragraph,
at this point the writer
is considering adding
the following sentence.
So this is a sentence that
would go right at the beginning
of this paragraph.
Scientists do not yet know
all the benefits of singing,
but the communal process that
singing in a choir provides
has many postive side effects.
Should the writer make this addition here?
So let me finish reading this paragraph.
But it doesn't seem an unreasonable thing,
this is what the, you know,
this is the concluding paragraph,
you kind of want to tie
everything together,
and so this is really
what the passage is about,
scientists do not yet
know all the benefits
of singing, but the communal process
that singing in a choir provides
has many positive side effects.
The second part, the communal process
that singing in a choir provides
has many positive side effects
seems to be what the passage is about,
but let's see how they
close out the paragraph.
So if we went with this,
so it has many positive side effects.
>From the changes in
heartbeat and breathing
that result in a healthier heart,
to the reduction of cortisol,
and the production of endorphins
that lower stress and increase happiness.
So it does look like it's listing the
many positive side effects,
so I'm feeling pretty good about this.
And then, well, this
is actually over here,
isn't a complete sentence,
it's saying from the changes in heartbeat
and breathing that result
in a healthier heart
for the reduction of cortisol
and production of
endorphins that lower stress
and increase happiness,
then we go into question 11,
there should be a comma here
to kind of complete this,
we're saying from this to that to this,
and then we need to make our statement.
So there should be a comma,
choir singing fulfills humans
by letting them create art
while being part of a group.
So this is good, let's go
straight to question 11,
put that comma in there.
Luckily there's a choice
that has a comma here.
'Cause it's really just completing,
we're just starting it, saying from this
to that to that,
now let's make our statement,
comma, let's make our statement,
you need a complete,
just the from part right over here
that is not a complete sentence.
So with that out of the way,
that we want to put a comma here,
and not start a new sentence,
let's go back to question ten.
So let's see, so the choices are, yes,
we could put this first thing
because it reinforces the
primary claim of the passage.
Yeah, it doesn't seem crazy.
Let's just read that again,
scientists do not yet,
let's start with this,
scientists do not yet
know all the benefits
of singing, but the communal process
that singing in a choir provides
has many positive side effects.
>From the changes in
heartbeat and breathing
that result in a healthier heart
to the reduction of cortisol
and production of endorphins
that lower stress and increase happiness,
comma, lowercase C,
choir singing fulfills
humans by letting them
create art while being part of a group.
Yeah, this whole everything right here
is actually going to be one sentence
because we're going to put the comma here.
And so to start with this
we don't know all the benefits,
but it has many positive side effects
and then we list them all here,
and then we say choir fulfills humans
while letting them create art
while being part of a group.
Yeah, I like this.
It's a yes because it offers
additional information
that supports the claim of the passage.
Now this doesn't give
us any new information,
it's just tying things together,
so I wouldn't pick B.
No, because it provides
information unrelated
to the passage.
Well, first of all, it
is related to the passage
but it's not providing new information,
so choice C is definitely not the case.
No, because it distracts from the focus
of the previous paragraph.
No, if anything it's kind of a nice tie in
from the previous paragraph
because the previous paragraph was saying,
All these clues we have
about the different ways choir singing
might help the brain.
And but you know these were just clues,
we don't know exactly how the brain works,
we don't know exactly the mechanism
by which choir singing makes our brain
do all of these positive things,
so it's nice that they said
that they don't know
all of the answers yet,
but, and then it does have
many positive side effects,
and then we list those side effects
and we kind of close it all up together.
Yes, so I feel good
about A for question ten.
And then B for 11,
where we definitely don't want this thing
over here in the public sentence.
And once again, I'm using
a prototype version of this
so this is a little bit of a (mumbling)
it says question 11 out of 11.
Anyway, you get the point.